au maroc l'interdiction de trois
journaux au troisième de madère par le
gouvernement de monsieur youssouf y
provoque de très nombreuses réactions le
premier ministre marocain affirme que
ces journaux discréditait le pays
portait atteinte aux institutions
différentes organisations
internationales appuie les hebdomadaires
interdite qui ont saisi la cour suprême
marocaine et fait appel au roi mohamed6
commentait jérôme baugnies avec patrice
sanden en visite officielle à berlin le
premier ministre socialiste du maroc ne
peut éviter la question sur un acte qui
ternit son image d'homme de l'alternance
l'interdiction de trois grands journaux
marocains
j'ai été attristée par le travail de
sape et de discrédit d' atteinte à la
crédibilité du pays à laquelle s'est
livrée
une partie de la presse quelques jours
loin des journaux qui ont osé lever un
tabou celui qui entoure l'attentât
manqué doute 72 contre le roi du maroc
la version officielle avait toujours
désigné comme seul coupable
le général oufkir homme de confiance du
roi éliminer le soir même mais selon les
révélations des journaux interdits
plusieurs dirigeants socialistes
auraient été mis dans le secret du
putsch hypothèse le roi hassan ii aurait
ainsi pu tenir son opposition de gauche
pendant toutes ces années
jusqu'au jour où ils appellent au
pouvoir le socialiste abderrahmane
youssoufi
en tout cas en interdisant trois
journaux le premier ministre marocain
reprend une pratique qu'il a lui même
combattu pendant 30 ans dans cette
affaire il n'y a aucune atteinte à la
sûreté de l'état
nous avons fait un travail
journalistique simple et directe
c'est-à-dire que nous avons révélé fallu
à l'opinion publique des faits
historiques qui sont méconnus
les défenseurs des droits de l'homme se
retourne vers le roi mohamed 6 mai dans
l'entourage de son premier ministre
on laisse entendre que cette mesure
d'interdiction n'aurait pas été prise si
le palais et avait été opposé la mise en